Collin thank you for coming by well  thanks for having me  Oh Ronald oh my god you can see Colin at  the brokerage this weekend is that right  yeah yeah if it's the brokerage why  don't they fix it  ah Nixon with the play on words  Nixon oh isn't it I love ya fast let's  check us a dog of course you can see  chip Nixon in person ha in Philly yeah  chip Nixon all I am NOT a crook 11 kids  in Philly under in the debates like  Nixon oh what a horrible company about  Edgar Nicholson can you do him from  windy you should have a fine I like to  put together a jukebox open when Dean it  up hold on Travis's try he said jukebox  thanks for clearing that yeah yeah yeah  he thought it was rare game for Mom